12 est à présent face à la première
[Musique]
la vigilance jaune scientifique
déclenchée à la montagne pelée depuis le
début du mois de décembre 2020 au même
moment des éruptions effusive à la
soufrière de saint vincent et les
grenadines sont enregistrées la
soufrière en guadeloupe est toujours en
observation repenser le week-end gianni
enfouis sous des eaux au nord de grenade
continue de faire des siennes
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
l'activité volcanique est plutôt soutenu
dans l'archipel caraïbe
en vous souhaitant la bienvenue dans
face à la première ce dimanche 24
janvier 2021
pour ce nouveau numéro de l'émission
politique hebdomadaire de la rédaction
de martinique la première je vous
propose d'évoquer le volcanisme de la
caraïbe et qu'en martinique à la
réalisation en régie aujourd'hui edit le
curieux et patrice à la guise à la chine
tout d'abord je vous pouvez entre nos
invités et en commençant par monsieur
jean jacques boudon par téléphone
bonjour monsieur boudant bonjour vous
êtes à distance depuis paris où vous
résidez et travaillez vous êtes
volcanologues en poste à l'institut de
physique du globe de paris qui chapeaute
d'ailleurs nous y reviendrons totalement
les observatoires volcanologiques
français la réunion de la guadeloupe et
de la martinique
l'observateur de martinique dont vous
avez été le directeur on vous dit quand
vous avez commencé votre carrière de
1984 à 1990 à l'époque à lille était
situé au monde des candidats français
denis d euros mais depuis quelques mois
il est implanté à deux kilomètres de là
au monde la rosette à saint-pierre à
merci de nous rejoindre monsieur bouton
avec vous avec nos studios se trouve
tout d'abord bruno magalogue nomme jour
bonjour vous êtes professeur agrégé de
géographie membres et l'association haut
niveau la caraïbe existants vous avez
écrit l'article immédiatement après la
mise en vigilance ion de l'appeler et
donc votre association oyonnax caribou
que nous avons eu l'occasion de recevoir
ici diffuse les savoirs sur les sciences
sociales au public via un site internet
très bien fournie que je vous recommande
est en fait je suis content de nos
auditeurs et de nos internautes albéric
marcellin bonjour oui bonjour à tous les
auditeurs de vente unique la première
président fondateur de l'université
populaire de la prévention cette
association qui se propose de diffuser
l'information la sensibilisation sur les
risques naturels en général il est vrai
qu'en tant que militants syndicalistes
et associatifs depuis très longtemps
ça vous a amené tout naturellement à
vous intéresser à la manière dont nous
vivons dans notre pays aux chances de la
terre va dire voilà alors tout d'abord
quelqu'un définition si vous le
permettez monsieur bouton monsieur marc
gagnon renault monsieur marseillais pour
savoir ce qu'est volcan en quoi les
volcans et les séismes sont liés entre
eux
qu'est ce que l'on peut dire sur la
manière de vivre avec les volcans dans
notre archipel qui est particulièrement
observée par les sismologues par les
géographes par les volcanologues alors
tout d'abord monsieur bout d'homme pour
parler rapidement si vous aviez à vous
exprimer de la manière la plus simple
est ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler la
définition de ce qu'est un volcan un
volcan
c'est une c'est une réunion montagne
souvent qu'on voit donc en surface mais
qui ne représentent qu'une toute petite
partie parce qu'en fait sous ce broker
bien sûr il ya tout tout un système
d'alimentation magma de réserve et matic
de stockage de magma qui font que ces
bagues maman remonter à la surface
produire des éruptions qui vont
progressivement édifier un code volcan
stratovolcan en fonction de la durée de
l'activité
on peut être juste rappeler le l'origine
des volcans des volcans aux antilles
peut-être nous ce les antilles c'est un
arc noir volcanique qui est institué à
la subduction des plaques nord et sud
américains l'américaine sous la petite
plaque caraïbe qui est coincé entre la
entre sept plats qui subjugue et le et
la plaque pacifique et de l'autre côté
de d'amérique centrale et est donc cette
subduction donc en train de
l'enfoncement de la plaque océanique
sous cette plaque qui progressivement au
fur et à mesure de son enfance mans va
entraîner donc la production de magma ce
qu'on appelle de la fusion partielle et
ses vagues ma vont progressivement donc
remonter de la surface se stocker à
différentes profondeurs de la tourner de
30 km après remonté plus en plus haut
jusqu'à atteindre une zone qu'on
considère comme étant la zone ils ont la
plus la plus superficielle la zone de
stockage a pu faire si elle qui est
situé pour la plupart ces volcans autour
de 6 et 7 km de profondeur
et c'est à partir de cette zone de
stockage superficielle que les avons
remontés pour donner les
les éruptions donc qu'on connaît sur ce
vous avez cités sur les différents
volcans de la dette
alors je vous demande de quelques
mandats précision va reparler de
subduction mai encore oui alors donc la
subduction vous savez que la la land un
certain nombre de plaques tectoniques
qui sont qui se déplace donc le club est
constitué d'une série de packs
tectoniques et ses plaques tectoniques
donc se déplacent dus à des mouvements
de convection dans le manteau supérieur
et donc progressivement dans des zones
où de ces plaques s'écarte des îles par
rapport aux c'est ce qu'on appelle les
zones d'accrétion c'est ce qui se
produit par exemple au milieu de l'océan
atlantique on à la zone l'aride médio
océanique lui duo atlantique qui à
partir de là donc les mc barr au mans
par ces mouvements de convection et vont
progressivement donc produire des magmas
qui vont s'accumuler et écarter
progressivement les plaques et puis
comme la surface de la terre est
toujours la même les guerres des zones
où ces plaques pour disparaître et c'est
ce qu'on appelle les zones de subduction
lorsqu'une plaque s'enfonce où une autre
plaque
ça c'est ce qui produit donc beaucoup de
volcanisme c'est par exemple tout ce qui
se produit autour de du pacifique ce
qu'on appelle la ceinture de feu du
pacifique
et puis quand on a des plaques des
plaques qui ne peuvent pas s'enfoncer
l'unl une sous l'autre par exemple des
plaques quand on a encore des continents
eh bien ces plats qu'elles vont se se
confronter et c'est ce qui va générer
donc des chaînes de montagne comme par
exemple himalaya qui résultent
actuellement glas l'enfoncement de de
l'inde donc dans la plaque dans la dans
la dans le continent eurasien dans la
plaque eurasienne donc voilà mais la
subduction c'est l'enfoncement d'une
plaque sous une autre du à ces
mouvements de convection dans le manteau
et de rythmes scolaires
oui alors une question parce que dans la
littérature scientifique on entendait
que sur la planète il ya tous plaques
tectoniques et d'autres 10 14 est ce
qu'on peut avant une 40 et là tu
aujourd'hui notamment de la part de
l'ipgp est oui alors les plats qu'il y
en a disons un certain nombre de grandes
plaques tectoniques et puis après il ya
des microplaques et les microplaques
elle a bien plus de 2 14
et qu'ils sont des ddd partie de grandes
plaques qui arrivent à se déplacer donc
séparément avec des mouvements
différents
donc en fait le nombre de plaques donc
et bien il ya un certain nombre de
grandes plaques mais le nombre de
plaques à vent prenant compte six micros
plate est bien supérieur d'accord alors
je reviens vers un autre joueur avoue
une eau mag allongerait nos pour nous
expliquer bien le phénomène de ces
fameuses plaque caraïbe et amérique qui
s'y frotte l'une contre l'autre et l'une
attendre de rentrer seul autre qu'est ce
que c'est que ça il ya une vie
véritablement qui échappent à notre
contrôle soutien sous la mer donc il
faut bien vous comprendre ces plaques
justement son on peut considérer comme
des radeaux qui sont ces radios se
déplace grâce à des courants qui sont
sous les plaques et ses courants donc
peuvent avoir des directions différentes
et à partir de ce moment là il arrive
que les plaques dont comme l'indiqué
monsieur goût dont les plaques sont
marquées par des mouvements qui peuvent
être variables les unes par rapport aux
autres et donc la subduction elle c'est
quentin des radeaux c'est une question
de densité c'est quentin des radeaux
finalement coule sous un autre raddho
dis donc
7ce ce sinistre entre guillemets cet
effet de ce passage sous l'autre radeau
provoquent séismes et volcanique et
volcanisme pardon donc vous avez
vraiment c'est un système qui existe
effectivement comme l'a dit le
précédente interlocuteur c'est un
système qui existe partout de par le
monde donc voilà si je prends une image
dites moi si j'ai des bêtises puisque je
ne suis pas quelqu'un au log
mais tant qu'elle le globe terrestre en
fait c'est représentant la part une
orange ou un melon fait quelque chose
voilà de forme sphérique et la couche
supérieure c'est-à-dire la peau ce que
l'on voit en fait n'est pas homogène
comme le sont les fruits les melons les
anges mais est constitué de plusieurs
petits morceaux de de plus en quelque
sorte on se serait plutôt une orange où
on ne l'ont en train de pourrir avec
différentes plaques qui commença par le
fait de la avec des boursouflures avec
donc cette partie superficielle de ce
melon donc n'est pas stable et c'est
comme si la peau du melon se détachait
les unes par rapport aux autres donc si
je vous comprends bien quand une plaque
se frotte à une autre ça provoque un
conflit soit la création d'une chaîne de
montagne l'himalaya monsieur vous dire
toute alliance mais alors pour faire une
faille tectonique une faille entre deux
plaques tectoniques qui peut créer à ce
moment là des volcans sous marins et qui
au fur et à mesure émergent au dessus de
la surface de la mer dont les italiens
qu'en fait vous avez donc effectivement
le les différents types de mouvements
mais il ya effectivement la plaque qui
rentre saoul autres et puis vous avez la
plaque qui glisse par rapport à l'autre
c'est le cas par exemple de la faille de
san andreas en californie
et puis vous avez les deux plaques qui
sont quasiment de même densité on va
dire de radeaux identique et qui sont
donc ils se rencontrent qui forment donc
en collision et ça donne effectivement
les très grandes chaînes que l'on voit
actuellement mais effectivement nous
nous sommes dans les archipels plutôt
concerné par les phénomènes de
subduction c'est-à-dire leur a dit un
des radeaux qui coule sous l'autre tant
que la plaque amérique et la plaque
c'est en train de devenir plus complexe
mais pour la caraïbe c'est l'un ou
l'autre mais il ya des archipels où il
ya trois plaques qui peuvent justement
joué par exemple aux philippines au
japon là ça devient beaucoup plus
complexe puisque les trois plaques jour
les unes par rapport aux autres
alors messieurs bout de je vous disais
tout à l'heure que l'archipel des
caraïbes et énarque volcaniques mais
encore ça veut dire qu'il ya plusieurs
volcans comment la cité des noms à citer
quelques-uns il ya une petite dizaine de
vols qu'un que l'on considère comme
actif nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure
en coin il est particulier la queue
volcanique t à la caraïbe par rapport à
d'autres dans le monde
oui juste avant un jour et faire une
petite précision sur les plaques parce
qu'on a là on n'a pas parlé on a parlé
de deux de plat qui s'enfonce et une pi
ce qui sort qui se rencontrer mais en
fait il faut distinguer deux types de
journal ce qu'on appelle les plaques
océaniques qui sont formés par ce qui se
produit donc les vagues maquis sont
dispo qui sortent au niveau des zones
des zones de meilleur océanique et comme
la dorsale médio atlantique
qui sont des plaques océaniques c'est à
dire c'est principalement constitués
donc de basalte de roches denses et puis
les continents qui sont ce qu'on appelle
les plaques continentales et qui sont
constitués donc de roche qui sont plus
légères en fait cessé continent en fait
vont pas s'enfoncer sous une triple a
qui vont rester en surface et c'est pour
ça que quand on a un continent qui va
rencontrer un continent comme l'un des
leurs à ce débat il sent fort spam est
il celui se percutent et c'est ce qui
donne les chefs de montagne c'était
juste une petite pression que nous donc
pour revenir à la volcan de la caméra
est donc comme colisée on est sur la
sueur l'enfoncement de des plaques
l'atlantique sous la plaque caraïbe qui
cet enfoncement cette zone de subduction
donc elle débute au niveau de docteur
dessus des grandes antilles et elle va
jusqu'à pratiquement le grenade enfin
jusqu'à la limite donc de de trinidad au
dessus de trinidad tobago
et donc voilà donc on a cette production
cette fusion partielle au fur et à
mesure que la plaque s'enfonce la fusion
partielle donc de 2 qui va générer des
magmas et donc ils vont gérer il va y
avoir d'aidé des poches de magma qui
vont générer différentes et indifférente
à différents endroits
et si ce qui va créer que onze imams
formés quand on va voir ce qui va
entraîner la formation de volcans donc
non pas du tout utile tout et tout et
volcans jude qui sont très près les uns
des autres mais qui vont être espacés
donc de d'une certaine distance et ce
qui va former les volcans et
progressivement les îles et on voit que
sur les îles bas l'activité peut se
déplacer parce que la plaque se déplace
et donc on va avoir donc des volcans qui
vont se former par exemple à la
martinique on a des volcans qui sont
situées au sud au sud est de la
martinique la peau l'open de cette aide
par exemple la caravelle qui sont les
volcans les plus anciens qui sont
érodées maintenant qu'ils sont les
volcans plus anciennes qui sont dédiés à
peu près à 25 millions d'années et puis
on a une progression de l'activité
volcanique vers le nord ouest jusqu'à la
montée d'accord alors je reviens avec un
national alors raynaud un géographe
pacios toutes ces définitions
est ce qu'on peut dire pour prendre une
image que la frontière la couture entre
les deux plaques qui nous concerne
caraïbes et en amérique centrale
c'est à cette frontière cette couture
que si tu es l'unc des petites un tennis
alors lors des petites antilles en fait
ils se il se subdivise quand on regarde
bien il ya une partie beaucoup plus
ancienne qui est on parle d'or qui
externe qui concerne par exemple il de
barbade la grande terre en guadeloupe
qui ne sont pas des terres actuellement
volcaniques qui sont des terres de
sédimentation coralliennes et donc qui
ont donné des îles plates ou
apparaissent aujourd'hui on est
formation des désirs aux ions chimique
de la roche calcaire
voilà comme marie galante tout à fait et
puis vous avez donc la partie de
volcanisme externe pour simplifier un
peu drôle canil ce qu'on appelle la rhk
interne qui donc porte actuellement les
volcans les volcans dits actifs ou qui
ne sont plus qu'ils ne sont plus actifs
et donc cet ensemble est plutôt beaucoup
plus montagneux donc c'est par exemple
la particularité de la guadeloupe qui
n'est que séparer cet art ne sépare que
par un bras de mer entre la marque
externe et l'arc interne avec la basse
terre tout à faire ça à l'inversé 21
alors est-ce que les les îles sur
lesquels nous habitons de trinidad
puisque à cuba est ce que c'est ils sont
des terres immergées intéressante et des
volcans sous marins qui ont pris avec le
temps au fur et à mesure plusieurs
éruptions qui ont pris le temps de
monter de franchir en toute la
profondeur entre le manteau de la terre
il à la surface de la mer c'est un peu
ça oui c'est un peu ça c'est pour ça que
monsieur bouton parler de stratovolcan
c'est vraiment par éruption successives
vous avez donc au fur et à mesure ça
sort de l'osce a émergé donc et ça
construit des phénomènes plus ou moins
complexes de deux territoires et de
relief
donc ça veut dire que l'île de la
martinique monsieur boudent n'est pas
issu d'une seule éruption sous marine
mais de plusieurs dans le temps passe au
talent au bout de barney de la caravelle
qui a une période qui a paru une période
différente de celle de la montagne pelée
bien sûr ces s'est constitué d'une
multitude de volcans et chaque volcan
est constitué du déformé par une
multitude d'éruption donc on a en a une
activité voyez on voit que l'acte i
invité par exemple à la montagne pelée
on y reviendra mais ces quelques
quelques éruptions magmatique par
millénaire et si on monte on remonte sa
sur plusieurs dizaines de millions
d'années voyez ça fait des quantités
d'éruptions qui vont progressivement
édifier des édifices et puis l'activité
base s'est légèrement déplacé parce que
là les plaques bougent les opérateurs
zodiac la subduction se déplacent ce
type est donc ça va entraîner dont il
une production de magma petit peu décalé
qui va redonner donc de nouveaux volcans
et ainsi de suite
or il la martinique était vecteur est
l'exemple l'inde est le seul exemple
dans l'ain dans la caraïbe où on a
vraiment la juxtaposition de deux du
volcanisme on peut retracer l'activité
depuis 27 condamnés jusque jusqu'à
activités actuelles allah allah à la
montagne pelée donc pour ça c'est une
île très intéressante
donc si je comprends bien là l'île de la
martinique est la résultante de
multiples the witcher volcanique depuis
25 millions d'années et qui donc des
volcans qui se sont superposées les
aider oui des éruptions que les unes
après les autres et c'est en fait c'est
très progressif il n'y a pas une
éruption qui a fait exploser le maghreb
qui a remonté 6000 mètres dos non c'est
pas exactement comme ça non non ça s'est
progressivement et ses volcans inès à
une certaine profondeur et donc ils vont
former des édifices ou marin qui vont
progressivement monter monter jusqu'à ce
qu'ils arrivent au niveau de la surface
de la mer qui vont émerger et on a un
exemple de deux volcans sous-marins
réactif vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
du week-end génie qui est située sur la
bordure nord ouest de l'île de la
grenade et c'est un volcan qui a une
activité répondantes sainement le volcan
le plus actif de la de la zone caraïbe
et kiki et soir elle sur son sommet est
actuellement situé à 180 mètres de
profondeur dans ce niveau de l'avers et
l'encré 10e sur fréquentés on peut
imaginer que dans quelques dents
quelques
siècle dans quelques dizaines d'années
quelques siècles eh ben ce volcan sortir
de l'eau ah oui donc que ça veut dire
qu'ils continuent de vivre et de donc
c'est un peu juste
c'est ce que oui allez y messieurs et
nous avons fait avant nous avons
travaillé beaucoup donc sur la sur
l'ensemble des volcans de haut niveau de
la city physique du globe si l'ensemble
des volcans de l'arc et nous avons fait
beaucoup de campagnes océanographiques
pour justement quand un véhicule est un
volcan quand quand on est sur une île
bas c'est bien on étudie ce qui à terme
et en fait il ya une grande partie la
plus grande partie qui part en mer et
donc on a fait beaucoup de campagne ce
n'est graphique pour faire la
bathymétrie pour faire des prélèvements
des carottages pour étudier donc tout ce
qui passe t'il pas servir et on a pu
observer qu'il y avait une multitude de
petits de petites pointes mans notamment
quand je vous disais donc les le
volcanisme localisé entre dans les îles
entre ces îles par exemple entre la
martinique et la dominique on a une
multitude de petits points de man sous
marin qui se sont formés en client parra
qui n'ont pas grandi mais on a une
boutique et 2 2 devant le cordon en fait
on peut on peut observer qu'il ya des
quantités de volcans sous marins qui
sont qui sont qui sont restés à l'état
sous marins mais donc l'activité est
très importante ou permanente depuis
plus de 25 millions d'années mais plus
de 40 millions d'années
donc si je comprends bien bueno magallon
créneau le cliquet mme jenny volcan sous
marin comme on y va évoluer comme a
évolué par exemple la paix l'état du
corps jo il va sortir de l'eau par
ericsson successifs c'est un peu c'est
là qu'il faut redonner enfin visible oui
c'est ça les fasse sortir il va émerger
et puis ben si c'est une île entre
guillemets habitable peut-être que
l'état de grenade va va le colonisé se
seront chez volcanique et ensuite voilà
quoi et à partir du moment ça va devenir
un espace habité occupés par l'homme
on aura une autre problématique je vois
qu'à leur histoire en écoute avec la
plus grande attention les explications
n'ont pas tout à fait parce que je crois
qu'il faut dire les choses clairement
bon il y aura une ou de plusieurs lacs
arrive après une éruption majeure depuis
quelques années 80 c'est la même chose
parce que si on compte maintenant se bat
pour ça c'est la première chose
la deuxième chose donc c'est que je
voudrais citer mais césaire qui est
dedans
de ses écrits disait que nous sommes un
crachat de volcans puisque la valentine
et que comme ça a été dit tout à l'heure
et la résultante de plusieurs accidents
botanique sous-main joue vraiment venir
quand même sur la question des plaques
passion de la musique ska très vite la
tuque puisque cette association fait son
appel de l'organisation scientifique et
on a oublié de dire que l'épaisseur des
plaques si pas l'épaisseur d'une polo
c'est comme ça donc c'est quand même
relativement épais donc s'est plaint que
tectonique à peu près 70 km d'épaisseur
et quand les deux froide pour faire de
la subduction donc je laisse imaginer
aux uns et aux autres ce que selon vous
êtes comme une énergie qui est accumulée
sa fin alors il ils sont 800 km et par
rapport à la par rapport au rayon de la
terre ccc tout petit c'est trop petit et
faible en effet si on le ramène à une
range s'est même pas l'épaisseur d'une
pause rend encore plus faibles ont mené
à la halle aurions d'ailleurs très bien
monsieur boudon nous allons passer à une
autre chapitre sur le site les relations
entre volcans 6 parce que mon petit
doigt me dit que vous avez beaucoup à
dire également sur sa wii face à la
première
nous sommes avec jean joue donc un
mouvement né dans tant de l'institut de
physique du globe de paris ancien
directeur de l'observatoire
volcanologique et sismologique de
martinique albéric marcellin de
l'université populaire et de la
prévention et bruno maria longue raynaud
professeur de géographie à entre dames
en messieurs boudon il y a des relations
entre le volcanisme et le nôtre le
phénomène volcanique
il est séisme même si on ne sait pas
très bien la population ne sait pas très
bien faire le lien entre ça et ce en
quoi les deux phénomènes sont ils
heureux liés oui alors bien sûr quand on
a une cantona il qu une zone de
subduction comme la chorale comme la
zakât il en a donc bien sûr des 6
millions on peut on peut distinguer deux
types de ses 19 ans d'un séisme qui sont
dus au fait que ces plaques elles sont
originales sont pas et donc et donc
elles vont voter les unes contre les
autres que les contraintes vont
s'accumuler et de temps en temps ça va
casser et c'est ce qui crée ici c'est
pour ça qu'on a une activité sismique
extrêmement important donc sur tout
l'arc parce que les plaques s'enfonce
progressivement et il leur rigidité fait
que ça et les laissent assez bien
contraint de s'accumuler que ça casse
d'un seul coup donc on a beaucoup de 6
dans des très gros séismes des dents
dont on doit parler de lui du site 1140
de 1800 et de l'entraîneur physique car
trois greffes ou 1839 et donc ce sont
ceux sont dus au fait que les
contraintes se sont accumulés en ayant
ce sera libérée brutalement et donc ces
séismes ont fui quand on étudie ces
séismes et par exemple observatoire de
volcanologique de la sismologique de la
deûle à martigues carro jce bien sûr les
séismes sur l'ensemble de la sur la zone
martinique et même au delà
et on voit que ces séismes et bah on
peut grâce à cette activité sismique on
peut suivre le l'enfoncement kobeissy de
la plaque je fais une certaine
profondeur jusqu'à 150 km de profondeur
à peu près de la plaque atlantique sous
la plaque caraïbe et puis après on a au
moins deux séismes parce que les plaques
commence à se réchauffer à fondre et
donc elles ne sont beaucoup moins rigide
et donc la halle à l'ailé contre est
donc ne seriez-vous coûts moindres
contraintes et donc on a moins de séisme
donc ça c'est lé séisme est liée à la
subduction et puis dans les plats qu'on
a des fractures des failles et donc on
peut avoir des séismes générés par par
par ces failles par exemple en 2004 un
séisme au sein
ce sont ces sept pas dû à la subduction
mais ce sont des failles qui sont
transverse et qui peuvent jouer aussi dû
à ces mouvements de des plaques et on a
notre type de séisme et c'est ce qui va
nous intéresser plus à la montagne pelée
c'est que lorsque le réservoir
magmatique donc rentrer en rentrant
pression ou qu'il ya des mouvements de
fluide donc alan profondeur ça peut
créer des séismes des séismes qu'on
appelle des séismes tech des séismes
volcaniques et donc ces séismes
ils sont plus distants plus directement
liées à la subduction mais ils sont liés
donc au aux contraintes dues à la
remontée du magma au social du magma à
la à la pression donc due au gaz qui
sont dans ces réseaux mais matic donc en
fait on peut distinguer ces deux types
de 6 qui seront bien sûr tous
globalement liés à la subduction puisque
c'est la cause principale
bruno magallon créneau donc les séismes
que nous ressentons ou pas ici sont tout
à fait naturellement expliqué nous
explique un point de vue de la nature et
il ne faut pas s'en alarmer outre mesure
takano vivre aux surprenants volcan nous
aurons des séismes
oui à partir du moment où il y à une
manifestation volcanique qui a il ya
deux il ya des séismes il existe des
séismes
d'accord mais le problème c'est que au
départ la plupart l'activité sismique
liée au volcan est imperceptible par
l'homme et nous on ressent surtout les
séisme de subduction
ce sont ceux là qui ont été les plus
destructeurs mais effectivement une
activité volcanique génère des séismes
des fois ils sont tellement insensible
donc on les apports en âmes on leur
donne un nom différent l'ordre on les
appelle des traits morts
donc c'est pour indiquer que sous le dom
le stratovolcan le dom
cette espèce de vampire pustules conte à
la surface du globe
il y a une vie magmatique et cette vie
bague matic donc elle provoque de la
tension de la pression est parti de ce
moment là donc du coup les couches
géologiques peuvent éclater sous là et
ils savent très gênant et toute une
série de petits séismes qui sont
inhabituelles pour les populations qui
vivent à la surface mais qui sont sans
grand danger au fur et à mesure
d'ailleurs c'est un indicateur
d'intensité de l'activité volcanique
plus lettrés morts sont forts et se
rapproche donc voilà monsieur boudon
sera mieux expliquer que moi et puis
l'autre grand type de cic celui là
qui effraie le plus parce que c'est le
plus spectaculaire où vous avez
quasiment dont une avec la diffusion des
ondes sismiques mon pour pouvoir
comprendre comment fonctionne ce séisme
là il y avait déjà valu dans un ouvrage
est un étudiant de monsieur tazieff qui
comparaît donc ce processus de de séisme
de subduction à une malle que vous
poussez sur le sol donc en imaginant que
la plaque vous ne vous êtes en train de
pousser votre mal et votre mal rencontre
grains une pierre une roche est donc un
moment donné vous allez donc stoppée et
puis vous allez pousser pousser
davantage jusqu'à ce que vous puissiez
vaincre les obstacles et donc vous allez
libérer une force qui compte 24 cette
force libéré par exemple et que à la
surface de cette force libérée il ya des
immeubles et maisons tout s'effondre
tout subi l'ondé sismique et en fonction
de la capacité à s'adapter à cette onde
vous allez avoir plus ou moins de dégâts
d'accord justement parlant de dégâts car
cela vous avez étudié cette question
nous sommes entre deux anniversaires
triste 11 janvier 1839 la destruction de
fort-de-france et la mort de plusieurs
centaines d'habitants lors de ce séisme
du jamais vu à 39 cas une importance
sociale pour nous en dirons viendront
tout à l'heure et puis le 8 février 1843
messieurs vous dois parler tout à l'an
3000 morts environ à pâte à pitre
capitale de l'avoir entièrement des
trucs à ce moment là un coin s'appelle
nous était un peu de nous intéresser des
d'évoquer ses serveurs qui ne sont pas
très très anciens d'ailleurs mais il ya
lucie p honey qui est une jeune
géographe à anthony 15 qui les a tout
récemment dans l'émission résonance que
s'il n'y a pas de mémoire il ne peut pas
y avoir de culture du risque et ça j'ai
trouvé ça formidable comme citation donc
nous on essaie de faire un travail sur
la question de la mémoire simplement
pour rappeler aux gens que certains
vendredis en janvier 1839 à 5h55
commotion puisqu'à l'époque on ne disait
pas un séisme on disait comment surestep
à fort-de-france et fo royal bons et il
ya eu quand même quatre mille personnes
décédées et 28 blessés bon donc c'est
quand même une affaire très importante
puisque nous étions dans la période de
l'esclavagé
cinq ans après 8 février 1843 c'est la
guadeloupe avec un bouquin magistral la
pratique n'existe plus
donc ainsi le café entre 6000 et 2020
sont décédés ça c'est la première chose
mais derrière il ya eu ce méga incendies
qui a fini de consumer tout ce qui
pouvait rester sur pointe-à-pitre et
ailleurs bon donc ce sont deux éléments
de référence porno parce que tout le
travail de prévention que nous faisons
justement c'est à partir de ces deux
événements historiques l'assuré
martinique et sur la guadeloupe pour
dire aux gens que les phénomènes
sismiques
ce sont des phénomènes cycliques et en
cela on reprend une citation d'un ancien
écrivain trek qui s'appelait plutarque
et qui avait dit un jour là où la terre
a tremblé et la terre tremblera bon et
ça ça se vérifie sur l'ensemble de la
planète
donc on n'est pas là pour faire paniquer
les gens on est simplement là pour leur
dire attention on a eu quand même ce
fameux jeudi 29 novembre 2007 à 15
heures précises banques qui n'était pas
le seul puisque la localisation était
sur la plaque 1 donc entre le prêcheur
et la dominique et là bon c'est un
séisme pédagogique dans la mesure où ça
rien morse un petit peu l'action puisque
bon alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu quatre
morts quand même ce jour là il faut le
dire alors que justin mapp pourquoi il
est important pour nous de ces 11
janvier dès 6h30 9h30 unique parce que
c'est lié à la période carnavalesque ya
aussi alors on sait bien qu'il ya une
disposition qui avait été prise par la
municipalité de foyal à l'époque qui
interdisait que le carnaval ne commença
à fort de france avant le 11 janvier
si je vous salue la mémoire de toutes
ces personnes disparues mais en tout cas
pour nous ce qui est important c'est
pour rappeler aux gens que j'aime et on
considère que le 11 janvier 10 139 le
stock d'énergie qui avait été accumulé
dans la zone de subduction a été libéré
et le phénomène de subduction avons
commencé avec les plaques équipe qui
frotte et qui glissent l'une sur l'autre
arrivant à peu près de 2 cm chaque année
et que bon il ya là aujourd'hui un stock
extrêmement important puisque paul
taponier qui est un ancien de l'ipgp et
l'institut physique du globe de paris
est venu sur la zone de subduction et ya
de cela une bonne dizaine d'années pour
poser les capteurs et lorsqu'il a
commenté franck hubert qui est dans mon
association d'autres grandes connaît que
je salue qui est architecte très très
fort sur la question du parent sismique
eh bien lorsque nous avons rencontré
pour le taponier il n'a pas manqué de
nous dire que vous étiez sur une bo
géologique et qu'il avait le sentiment
que en matière de prévention qui ne se
passait pas grand chose et non
s'évertuera à lui dire mais oui on fait
des conférences on a à peu près six
mille personnes chaque année qui
participent à nos conférences
il nous dit oui mais c'est super ce que
vous faites mais c'est important de tout
ce qui est à faire donc c'est pour ça
que lorsqu'on a vu à huer le plan séisme
antilles numéro 1 en 2007 suit juste
voir décès de la petite fille de 11 ans
à trois rivières en guadeloupe à
l'occasion du séisme des saintes
enfin sylvain tisne au un plan séisme
antilles nu et o2 qui n'a pas beaucoup
fonctionné parce qu'il ya pas eu
beaucoup de projets là dans les tuyaux
et le rial plan séisme antilles numéro 3
que le gouvernement essaie de réamorcer
d'accélérer pour qu'on ait le maximum de
bâtiments de la classe des bâtiments
stratégiques mises aux normes pour nous
permettre d'avoir des éléments de la
résilience dans la gestion de crise quoi
parce que c'est ça qui nous guette n'est
pas pendant que les plans sont en train
d'être élaboré que nous nous préparons
éventuellement à une nouvelle un nouveau
grand séisme nouvelle éruption
toujours est il que l'activité
volcanique reste extrêmement soutenue
l'arc des petites antilles cote
d'après li pgp et j'ai de bonnes
lectures n'est ce pas monsieur vous
donne neuf volcans actifs parmi lesquels
la souffrir de guadeloupe la souffrir de
saint-vincent soufrière hills de
montserrat dans l'éruption de 1995 a
duré longtemps les week-ends génie que
nous avons parlé et la montagne pelée
une petite question au fait qu'il peut
expliquer pourquoi il ya autant de
volcans qui s'appelle soufrière de la
caraïbe a rien à 5
oui il y en a 5 2 revient bien
montserrat guadeloupe dominique sainte
lucie saint vaast sont en effet alors
pourquoi oui bruno magalhaès benoît zone
à une explication si voilà je pense que
monsieur boudoir mieux placé que moi
parce que la notion de soufre ihas un
type de volcans avec les émanations donc
sulfuré plus en surface et donc
peut-être que monsieur moudon bois mais
monsieur goodhand sollicité c'est tout à
fait ça ce site a fait ça ce sont des
volcans qui ont des des émanations des
fumerolles et des zones fumerolles yen
face au fath rien extrêmement importante
avec beaucoup de dégagement de 2
s'offre de gaz et que ce soit là
souffrir guadeloupe la soufrière de
montserrat ce free arrive à souffrir de
celui-ci aussi donc ce sont des volcans
qui ont cessé grandes zones donc cotre
très très active des systèmes d'eau
thermale qui dégage beaucoup de degas
souffrez donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
donnée le d'autres souffrira c'est assez
différente différentes zones et donc à
ces volcans donc celui de la montagne
ballet et n'est pas une chaufferie à
c'est un autre type de volcans vous avez
vous voyez la montagne pelée
il ya très peu de zones d'émanation de
fumées
il n'y a pas de n'y a pas de fumerolles
actuellement à la vente elle colle et il
y en a eu après l'éruption de 1902 après
l'éruption de 1929 mais c'est plus drôle
se sont progressivement tahri et donc
non pas donc on n'a pas de on a passé
ces zones donc bien qu'on a un système
notamment alors on pourra en reparler de
ce que c'est que si c'est le terme à la
paix mais rendent pas ça existe soul sur
le monde sous la montagne pelée mais on
n'a pas donc ces zones de dégazage
portant permanent donc de de gaz de gaz
soufrés gaza si on parle de volcans
actifs n'ont qu'une vie qui ont une
activité qui produisent des phénomènes
que nous venons de décrire notamment les
séismes mais est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il ya des volcans endormis peut-on
parler de volcans endormis cette
expression était impropre
scientifiquement parlant monsieur bouton
alors les volcans endormis les volcans
dont ils sont quand ils sont en période
d'inactivité on peut considérer qu'ils
s'en est remis jusqu'à là jusqu'à six
directives b bord on appelle ces volcans
alors on a des volcans campus dont vous
savez si tu es en fait on a tous volcan
de décider des volcans cias à 1 et vis à
saint kitts aussi qu'ils sont des
volcans qu'on considère non pas
complètement qui sont pas éteints qui
sont toujours actifs qu'on peut
considérer que comme en or mais parce
qu'ils sont pas eu d'activité dans les
dents les derniers billets d'années mais
qui reste quand même des volcans qui
sont susceptibles de redonner des oeufs
durs on a connu dans le passé
prabhakaran mais sur d'autres volcans
des volcans qui avait pas eu d'activité
pendant plusieurs milliers d'années et
qui se sont réactivés comme par exemple
le pinatubo aux philippines en 1991 et
est un volcan
pas considéré comme éteint mais qui
était très peu actif très peu actifs et
donc donc voilà donc on a des volcans
qui sont eux qui ont une activité donc
fugro lienne permanente comme la
souffert guadeloupe
et puis notre volcan qu'on la montagne
pelée qui entre les irruptions ben on
voit pas grand chose d'un peu de données
sur ce choc qui pourrait aussi
montevideo en température mais on a pas
grand chose qui se passe en surface
bruno magalhaes a que ce sont des
volcans et merci bruno magalhaes venant
toutes les îles procède l'éruption
volcanique au pluriel ancienne mais
toutes les îles que nous connaissons qui
sont immergés dans ces terres immergées
ne sont pas forcément des vols quand je
parle je pense aux grandes antilles cuba
haïti jamaïque république dominicaine
porto rico ou encore à l'extrême sud
robin abonnés encore à sauterie n'daw ne
sont pas à proprement parler on y avait
des points de vente ayant une activité
volcanique par contre il ya de la
sismicité
donc non il n'ya pas les volcans actifs
pour l'instant sont effectivement au
niveau des petites antilles et puis sur
l'arc en face d'amérique centrale si on
prend l'ensemble
alors il y à un volcan laki entré en
éruption il ya quelques semaines d'enfer
une option à s'offrir cette prière de
cms anguilles à quelques centaines de
kilomètres les mains tandis que cela
fait 400 km à vol d'oiseau à peu près si
je ne rentre le moins intéressant c'est
le nord de saint vincent labrune on est
tout près donc
alors
oui est ce qu'il ya une liaison une
relation entre la soufrière de ses
médecins et la montagne pelée parce qu
on se souvient que lors de l'éruption de
la plaie de 8 mai 1912 la veille le 7
mai à s'ouvrir de ses médecins étaient
entrés en éruption également oui mais la
soufrière de saint vincent est entré en
éruption 79 et en rien eu à la montagne
pelée
donc en fait il n'y a pas de il n'y a
pas de lien les volcans ne se donnent
pas la main dans le manteau terrestre et
puis se disent ce soit on va danser ou
bien cet os cette période si c'est on va
ouvrir le bal quoi donc
il s'agit pas d'une ronde des volcans
c'est ce sont des phénomènes
donc là il ya un réveil de la montagne
de saint vincent de la souffrir de ces
récents depuis 1979
bon il faut avoir en mémoire que la
montagne pelée avec son passage en
vigilance jaune finalement sa dernière
phase éruptive c'est qu'on a tendance à
l'eau m c'était 1932 donc ce n'est pas
si vieux que ça donc vous avez donc mais
les volcans ne sont pas en relation les
uns avec les autres
il n'y a pas de communication de
cheminée volcanique gens jouent donc
vous confirmez n'y a pas de lien
organique entre nous devons encore bien
sûr la cause de ce ou ces volcans
l'origine de ces vacances et c'est la
même c'est la zone de subduction donc
l'enfoncement des plaques sous la plaque
haye après comme je vous disais c'est
made my soul hybride généré ça va former
des télé poche qui vont monter depuis
depuis une trentaine de kilomètres de
profondeur et qui vont monter
progressivement et donc après ccc ccc
système de production de magma ils sont
complètement indépendants les uns des
autres et si la soufrière de saint
vincent et rentrer interruption la
veille de la pelée en 1902 et s'il en a
une éruption l'appeler qu'on appelle à
50mm que de recrudescence à l'appeler
c'est vraiment le le fruit du hasard y a
vraiment aucune connexion entre entre
ses différents rôles même avec le temps
est vrai que ce soit de souffrir le
pouleuf le souffrir de la communauté
scientifique internationale
ce sacre est passé le 7 mai 1912 quand
je cite notamment sarah bazin qui a été
direct et observatoires ici en
martinique eux et qui dans une émission
sur une télévision concurrente donc
en 2008 disait que les options du 7 mai
1910 fait à peu près de mille morts à
saint vincent et celui du 8 mai 1902
plus un glissement de terrain assez
extraordinaire quand même sur cette
lucie le 9 mai 1902 pouvait être la
résultante de séisme violent extrêmement
un bon temps
le 18 avril 1902 au guatemala et elle
explique que très probablement les deux
volcans de saint vincent et de la montée
de lait étaient mûres tant que le magma
était quand même déjà bien bien bien
bien installé à l'intérieur de de la
poche magmatique et que très
probablement saucisse du 18 avril 1902
au guatemala oui simplement précipiter
un petit peu les choses bon donc il ya
un débat dans la communauté scientifique
là dessus en tout cas bon je donne le
point de vue et ex trouver un demi lune
par sarah bazin riche en jouant bien sûr
oui bien sûr nommé est sûre ça c'est
l'essai c'est vrai on a on a observé en
effet que des gros tremblement de terre
peuvent dés on a eu en hausse en
capitaux watts et malingre autrement
terre qui s'est produit une année ou
deux années avant l'éruption de 2910
aussi émis à 102 c'est une extrêmement
importantes éruptions donc au sur ce sur
ce volcan le santa maria 200 cavaria
sentiers quito et donc en effet quand
quand en réserve avec matic donc et
commencent à rentrer en surpression
on va avoir donc bien sûr des débuts une
une ssii peu comme une cocotte minute
et si vous avez un gros séisme qui
arrivent même à une certaine distance et
bien il peut entraîner donc une mais des
modifications de contraintes donc dans
ce très sympathique et favoriser donc le
la fracturation et l'ouverture donc vers
vers la surface mais donc en effet et là
on est en train de regarder justement la
sicilia des séismes en a parlé on a des
séismes et fort qu'ils sont produits pas
très fort mais s'il n'y a pas une
relation avec ccc séisme et puis une
petite réactivation donc 2
de l'avancé les mets mais il faut que
les systèmes comme vous le dit tout à
l'heure il faut que les systèmes soient
mûres c'est à dire qu'on va un séisme ne
va pas déclencher une éruption
si le réservant magmatique sous ce
volcan est déjà prêt à rentrer en
production entre le celi le séisme
accélère un petit peu le la chose c'est
à dire que le volcan se terrent entré en
éruption quelques années après donc le
service va être le déclencheur mais ce
n'est pas disons le la cause de
l'éruption il faut que le système soit
déjà à maturité pour qu'ils rentrent en
direction avant d'un ben laden alimente
de l'émission et la question de savoir
comment vivre avec contre ou sous le
volcan deux petites questions rats qui
appelle une réponse brève
monsieur bouton puis monsieur magal en
vélo sur le site de l'observatoire de la
montagne pelée ou de l'ipgp et
l'institut de physique du globe de paris
on voit que les éruptions nos dates ne
sont pas datées psion un jour 8 mai 1902
mais on vous parlait des options de 1902
et 1903 pour parler de l'option de 1929
à 1932
monsieur mag alors une usine tout à
l'heure que la dernière phase éruptive
de la polizia 2932 mais elle avait
commencé plusieurs années auparavant
on a dit aussi on lit aussi que les
options de 1902 en fait elle a commencé
les premiers signes en encourant étaient
visibles à postériori dès 1889
autrement dit une éruption volcanique
c'est pas comme l'appui c'est un
phénomène brouille ce que c'est bien ça
monsieur
bien sûr que non bien sûr si on prend
les ruptures de 1902 en effet au nord
leur activation 89 on sait pas très bien
parce qu'on a plus du tout d'information
après jusqu'au début mais au début de
l'année 1901 on commence à avoir des
descriptions donc de fumerolles soul sur
le sommet d'un monticule et donc on a en
effet ils ont des think i qui est qui et
qui arrive à montrer qu'il va se passer
quelque chose et donc après donc le 8
mai 1902 d'ancona le en fait on le wagon
arriba arriba surface le l'antre dans la
nuit du 5 au 6 mai on pense puisque les
gens voient des dd lui envoie des des
show solo au sommet du volcan et donc on
a cette première explosion et puis après
on a toute une série de deux grosses
explosions le 8 mai le 20 mai au 6 juin
le 30 août qui est la dernière qui est
extrêmement violente et qui affecte la
halle
ville de borderouge puisqu'elle fait
encore 1500 dans la vie devant le rouge
et perd près le volcan continue le
d'hommes continuent à s'édifier à
s'écrouler progressivement donc il vaut
qui vend les écroulements vont produire
des coûts ce qu'on appelle des coulées
pyroclastiques qui vont s'écouler dans
la dans la rivière blanche qui vont
combler la rivière blanche et l'activité
à se produire jusqu au début de l'année
1900 sec et en 1929 c'est pareil
l'activité comment ce type quelques
quelques mois avant on commence à avoir
des signes et puis le magma arrive en
surface en novembre 1929 et se termine à
la fin de deux ans je sais pas
exactement mais enfin en 1932 donc ce
sont des éruptions qui peuvent durer
plusieurs années et on a le cas de
l'éruption de la soufrière de saint
vincent qui de fond c'est henri l'amant
serra qui a débuté en 1995 les premiers
signes les premiers ciné premier
tremblement terre ils se produisent en
1992 c'est à dire trois ans avant de
1995 donc les éruptions fatigué après
l'arrivée du magma est en érection c'est
pratiquement poursuivie jusqu'en 2010 on
a encore un petit peu de dégazage m'en
fait pendant pendant 15 ans donc cette
réduction a duré au moins deux de
production magmatique pendant 15 ans en
fait on allie volcan qui unit émulsions
c'est pas une explosion et puis ça
s'arrête
c'est disons ça ça dure longtemps et si
katia du magma qu'à la surface c'est pas
ça ça ça peut durer plusieurs années
face à la première j'en est parti
le volcanisme de la caraïbe et la
martinique si le thème de notre
commission aujourd'hui vous venez
d'entendre jacques boudon ancien
directeur de l'observatoire sismologique
et volcanologique de montagne pelée de
martinique actuellement profession de
volcanologie à l'institut de physique du
globe de paris nous avons avec nous
albéric marcellin le président fondateur
de l'université populaire et de la
prévention que nous entendons d'ailleurs
tous les jours vous l'avez entendu hier
encore samedi avec pascal l'embrun pour
distiller informations et surtout
sensibilisation aux risques naturels en
général
et puis bruno magalhaes meinau qui est
professeur agrégé de géographie vivre
sous le volcan contre le volcan avec le
volcan quelle est la bonne expression
bruno magalhaès renault puis rythme
insolent est alors de toute façon
sûrement pas contre donc c'est une île à
la géographie commence à prendre son
intérêt une fois que l'aléa c'est à dire
le phénomène volcanique est compris
c'est à dire comment vont s'organiser
les sociétés qui vivent avec le volcan
donc ça ne peut pas être autrement
le personnel une fois visite à la
montagne pelée j'ai vu une christophine
elle était super donc ça veut dire que
le sol était très riche tant que ça je
pense qu'il faut il faut le rappeler
avec force les uns pour les autres
bon les flancs de l'appeler sur tout le
territoire pour faire paître les animaux
par exemple bon l'herbe
elle est très bonne en dehors donc il ya
toute cette richesse là et puis à tout
ce qu'on peut faire aussi avec la
géothermie le thermalisme les activités
sportives enfin bref tout le monde a
compris que bon il faut qu'on apprenne
qu'on apprenne pendant à vivre avec
notre volcan
même si un scientifique disait aussi
destin joue que la vo thanh pauline est
un volcan était mais c'est un volcan qui
peut pas s'approcher l'éruption j'ai
trouvé la formule très belle bon donc
elle ne peut pas son éruption mais ça
nous empêche pas de vivre avec mais là
je pense que tout le monde sait pas
quand la prochaine rame sera tout à fait
mais j'en profite quand même prononcé
quand même un message à ceux qui
écoutent l'émission c'est aussi le
château d'eau de la martinique 1 donc il
faut qu'on dise donc tous les projets
d'investissements qu'on pourrait
imaginer doivent respecter aussi cette
affaire là parce que on voit que depuis
deux ans dans une problématique de l'eau
qui a démarré dans le pays donc
mais passé le pied mois à l'est la
montagne pelée et je dis ça parce que je
pense que vous vous rappelez
en 2010 il ya eu un départ de feu sur la
vente de lait il ya eu 500 hectares qui
sont partis en fumée
il ya une polémique derrière aussi où
est le canadair de la martinique je fais
ma part j'ai vu quand même 500 hectares
en fumée sur le château d'eau de la
matinée que j'étais inquiète donc
aujourd'hui avec la problématique de
l'eau qui s'est exacerbée un peu le
message est lancé pâtir et ont failli
bras en l'air la montagne pelée
on a un premier temps martine quand même
il ya encore des gens qui sont
traumatisés par le souvenir qu'ils n'ont
pas par définition de l'éruption de 1902
et il se dit que beaucoup de jeunes ne
vont pas habiter investir ou de manière
pérenne à saint-pierre parce que volcan
répéter un jour qu'est-ce qu'il faut
passer de ça alors il ya une première
chose il ya une collecte internationale
qui a été fait après les autorisations
de 9 millions de francs d'anciens francs
à l'époque ça fait à peu près 22
millions d'euros donc une somme énorme
et on sait bien que tout cet homme
toute cette somme blague a été collecté
n'a pas été justement utiliser bon et je
pense que si on additionne voisin capter
les chinois les débats au dollar et de
saint pierre alors lieu départ je pense
que si tout cet argent la veille s'est
mis en place pour le développement du
nord caraïbes que le nom car elle ne
serait pas d'une situation est difficile
bon donc là il y à une commission de
vigilance volcan qui a été mise en place
et notamment christian à 20 km de saint
pierre est chargé de la partie comme on
dit ça rebond économique
donc il ya des choses qu'on peut mettre
en place la dans la période justement
pour permettre aux martiniquais de vivre
avec le volcan est de faire en sorte que
la zone soit en zone désertique argent
je vous dois il n'y a pas de raison
particulière de graines de vivre à côté
ou source oulaï du volcan sachant que
st-pierre et prêcheurs et même car mes
hommes en rouge ne sont pas les seules
villes qui sont concernés par une
éventuelle future éruption alors je
voudrais juste faire un petit rappel sur
l'activité là si vous permettez parce
que
on n'est pas on n'est pas fort n'est pas
tant à la veille d'une éruption il faut
pas être pas comme on a eu des crises
sismiques à la plaie du même type
vous savez que les séismes qu'on
enregistrera actuellement et ce sont des
petites des crises qui durent de trois
jours et qui s'arrêtent cédé 6 mhz qui
sont pas ressenties par la population
qui a eu une magnitude extrêmement
faibles qui sont donc ils sont très très
faible quand j'étais directeur
l'observatoire en 1981 que 85 86 on est
une crise sismique tout à fait
comparable avec des séismes pendant
pendant plusieurs mois
et puis et ben tout s'est arrêté il n'y
a pas eu de il n'y a pas eu de rupture
donc en fait c'est séisme ils sont ils
sont superficielles ils sont justement
je vous parlais de système hydrothermal
c'est à dire que vous avez des fluides
du communal des réserves magmatique sous
le volcan on a des fluides chauds un des
gaz qui remonte tout temps et puis l'eau
les les eaux de pluie les hommes et eric
héraud s'infiltre dans le volcan et leur
encontre de ses eaux de pluie et de co2
ces fluides chauds créer des des zones
des autochtones à ddd des mélanges donc
de c2c fluide acide souvent de saison et
donc on va créer ce qu'on appelle le
système no thermale look avec avec ses
eaux qui sont chaudes de plus ou moins
acide et qui vont qui alimentent par
exemple les sources chaudes permanente
donc à la montre il plaît et puis ben
rendent à un peu on peut avoir de temps
en temps donc bien justement est ce que
est ce que justement on parlait tout à
l'heure de lien avec des cils on a eu
quelques gros séismes donc il ya il ya
quelques temps il ya quelques années
est-ce que c'est pas directement ce que
c'est pas dijon des petits riens
justement qu'il ya dans le temps dans
cette zone là donc en fait ces séismes
sont liés actuellement donc à ces
mouvements de fluides chauds donc dans
ce système un qui est située à 4 2 3 km2
sous le sommet du volcan
et puis la vie et puis ça peut ça peut
s'arrêter là le ce que je dis et c'est
que le passage en en vigilance donc en
jaune n'est pas du tout irréversible
s'il ya plus d'activité on reviendra
donc au vert comme on le fait sur
certains sur le volcan où on n'a pas de
donna pas de deux de suite dans nos
tendances écrit cela voilà donc le temps
qu à la vigilance gens ne vaut pour les
expos les scientifiques pour les
il observé bien sûr rien pour lui marié
absolue marielle de 2 et donc ça permet
sont de renforcer donc les réseaux sont
déjà très développés n'ont pas
réinstaller encore quelques stations
supplémentaires pour être bien bien bien
bien sûr bien suivre toute activité si
vous aussi il ya une activité de surface
qui n'est pas actuellement
et donc voilà donc on va suivre mais
c'est que ce type de 2 de chris et moi
fréquentes qu'elles à se faire
gaudeloupe puisqu'on a souvent décrit
sismique la c4 de look mais elle arrive
choisi celle de 86 87 elle celle à venir
est et l'ice est pas l après midi à une
éruption et donc on peut avoir la même
chose donc il faut pas il faut pas que
les gens s'affolent pour le moment parce
que c'est un phénomène qui et puis de
toute façon ce phénomène qui est lent et
qui est qu'on va suivre régulièrement il
ya un observatoire qui est extrêmement
bien bien équipé pour ça donc quand même
servir se vivre sur ce que seront volcan
bien sûr on en a quand même l'avantagé
dans la caraïbe c'est qu'on a cette zone
de subduction la vitesse de la
subduction est très faible
elle est de 2 cm par an c'est fait par
rapport à certaines subduction dans le
pacifique sont de 10 à 15 cm par an et
donc cette faible vitesse de subduction
fait qu'on a une faible production de
magma et donc du coup et ben on a moins
d'éruption que dans nos dents dans
certains archipels où on a des
irruptions pratiquement continu donc
donc c'est déjà un avantage on voit bien
que sur un volcan comme la montagne
pelée ou sur volcans comme celui-ci il
n'y a pas une activité très importante
la dernière il n'y a pratiquement pas à
l'appeler les pratiques pour un siècle à
celui-ci il ya plusieurs siècles
marvel à montserrat donc l'activité de
montserrat elle s'est produite après
plusieurs siècles des activités en
voyant on a quand même une rythmicité
qui relativement qui est pas très élevé
est donc vivre avec son volcan basse et
accepter que le volcan puisse entrer en
éruption mais entre ces périodes
d'éruptions qui sont longues et part on
peut donc à l'échelle humaine on peut
vivre parfaitement et profiter de la
richesse de ce volcan qui en effet
produit dé descendre des cendres qui qui
qui sont vite ressaisis assez du verre
est la particularité de ce ver qu'ici
c'est qu'il va avec la
écoles et les hôpitaux rick passe se
transforme et va s'accélérer rapidement
et va libérer donc tous les minéraux qui
ferment que ccc sol sur les flancs du
volcan sont généralement très fertile
merci georges vous dans votre
participation brûle magallon que non il
n'y a pas d'autre raison d'être que mon
pessimiste ou créatifs par rapport à la
vie de notre volcan
non c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'il faut
essayer de comprendre qu' on a parlé
tout à l'heure de le crise volcanique
donc ça s'installe ça peut s'installer
dans la durée et à partir du moment où
vous avez une crise volcanique sévère
vous allez donc avoir un certain nombre
d'acteurs publics qui vont rentrer dans
une logique de prévention d'une
catastrophe est donc cette crise
volcanique va être va amener à par
exemple déplacer des populations
l'ordre d'évacuation mais quand la crise
volcanique duo plusieurs années vous
déplacer la population vers un autre
endroit elle se reconstruit et là ça
devient difficile de lui demander de
retourner et de revenir ça c'est produit
donc ça c'est pas par exemple le la
crise qu'on a pu observer dans le sud
basse terre scellier c'est ça a été
accélérée par par exemple l'épisode de
la soufrière
quand on a donné l'ordre d'évacuation à
tord ou à raison ça c'est une autre
polémique
on a permis à près de trente mille
personnes de sortir de cette partie de
la population de cette partie de la
guadeloupe augmenter l'attractivité de
pointe à pitre
si leur y avait de la place mais après
pendant plusieurs années pendant deux
trois ans les gens ne reviennent pas
nécessairement sur le lieu d'habitation
et on ne recrée pas l'entreprise
et si ce nouveau départ qu'il faut
prendre en compte et là ça ça relève
évidemment de large et ses jambes les
qualités politiques publiques et de rick
hansen pour le mot de la fin
c'est très simple principe de précaution
ok il ya trois mois on ne disait rien
sai seuls à souffrir de sa veste voilà
principe de précaution c'est cette
fameuse réunion qui est programmée par
le préfet que 3 février 2021 à 15h30 sur
l'actualisation du plan orsec volcan
voilà donc on fera comme si donc on met
en place un certain nombre de choses je
me relève annie points gagnent haut que
les structures les autorités les
municipalités concernées et surtout le
nord et surtout pendant le centre
et le sud s'organise au chaos voilà
principe de précaution c'est ainsi que
s'est conclu notre émission face à la
première d'aujourd'hui réalisé par
édiles que oui patrice à la glisse à la
chine vous pourrez la retrouver en
podcast sur notre site internet
martinique quel point la première point
fr dans quelques instants ce sera le
journal de la rédaction de matinée que
la première pour les dernières
informations je vous retrouve dimanche
prochain pour une nouvelle émission
et puis comme nous l'avons entendu et
compris dû à cette émission c'est pas
joue latika tremblay volcan papeete ce
n'est pas au premier séisme que le
volcan entre en éruption mais je balaie
pas nippon grade merci à bientôt
[Musique]
ça la première